[Music]
hello YouTube just lost my friends this
is grunge in here welcome to my eighth
episode of love in Tulsa Solyndra prota
from the black perspective in this
episode we are going to look at the
final moon eight Queen to d1 which
arises after the falling model Evo c5
Knight to f3 Knight to c6 d 4 C CAP to
d4 Knight captures d4 ePHI Knight to be
fine
Essex and when night launch on d6 square
we are going to chop it up with a bishop
and then challenge the White Queen with
Quint web 6
well obviously white place the main line
with Quint even well here black has two
major choices
number one Knight G to e7 however I like
the second option namely Queen to g6
which has a to marriage number one it is
attacking on e4 and number two it
stopped the white Bishop development
from their front square okay the main
line continued with Knight to c3
defending on e4 and we will churn out
this universal new Knight G to e7
looking for of a thematic defy break we
have reached one of the most important
position in this video and as I
highlight over here white has two major
theoretical move in this position now as
the theory is too big in this episode we
are going to only concentrate on the
move Bishop to e3 and in my next video
we are going to look at the moon h4
after Bishop to e3 here comes the first
important memory marker guys as no other
move makes sense except D Phi which you
have to deliver at this point
white has two choices but capturing with
the piece is obviously pretty bad one
as the simple reason is after night
captors defy here
you cannot capture with the pawn as
after night to be for white is having
some huge issues on the c2 square as
luke 2:7 simply Matt with Bishop to a5
so this variation is right out of the
equation more consistent responses Queen
captures defy but as I have covered in
Queen to d3 line the next move black is
very obvious Bishop to b6 trying to gain
champ on the Queen and by force
winning the pawn well how come because
white can play the move Queen to d3
right well he can but after night two
before that Queen is simply an overload
piece you might say what about Queen to
C Phi stopping black castling well
certainly black won't minded as he's
getting his pawn back with Queen
captures efore and I just like to show
you a simple game where after White
Castle black simply target the White
King with rook to see it and after
Bishop to d3 and the moon Queen to be
for the a to pawn is hanging and in the
game white made this elegant blunder a3
which allows black to deliver this
superb attacking stop just within the
opening by playing Knight to a4 so you
can see suddenly the pressure is
mounting on c2 and in the game even
though white find the best move Queen to
before he get this route shark
so obviously white bishop cannot capture
due to the mate and after the game
continuation came to be one black
quickly get the upper hand with the
following sequence Queen captures before
he captures before and now simple move
rook to c8 and if you carefully look at
this position not only white has a
double pawn on the Queen side but at
this point
black is apana and in a long run this
position is definitely favoring the
black camp
so obviously capturing with the piece is
a bad idea
so that's why mainline continue with he
captures defy and now yup you got it
Knight to be full the same tactical
pattern which happens in many of this
love in Tulsa Salim lines again white
cannot play a rook to see Vern due to
the simple move Bishop to a5 so white
has two choices one is to move the pond
with d6 and the second is Bishop to d3
if we continue with d6 then this is a
big time
error as after Knight captures C to
check King to e2 black has a very strong
move in this position
Knight to f5 so getting out of white
attack and creating pressure on the rock
and if white foolishly saved the rook
with let's say rook to c1 then black has
this dazzling moon knight captures III
and suddenly black emerge with a piece
of ass white current even touch this
noid due to the nasty Bishop to g4
Jericho so you can see how much forcing
this line is White has to now play the
move Bishop to d3 in order to protect
the C to pawn and you might think well
that hangs the G to pawn but at
the poison porn guys as after Queen
captures G to Bishop to e4 is a very
strong reply and I think it is white who
has the upper hand in that line so here
my recommendation is you should capture
this bishop with a check and after Queen
captures d3 again if you capture on g2
then castle on the Queen side as a
strong reply by white so black is
obliged to capture the screen and after
pawn takes d3 amazingly enough by force
we are reaching to this position and if
you check it in the database
surprisingly enough there are only 26
games has been played so this is still a
new territory for many white players now
from those 26 games the 19 games has
been continued with Bishop to a5 which i
think is old moon and not so
surprisingly white has won some good
games with the accurate response Bishop
to b6 so that's the reason why I am
going to introduce the other strong
option namely B file which has been only
played in the 7 games here White has
three major choices and let's see each
by term now in almost all the games
White has continued with d6 so we need
to look at first when after this black
response is very obvious he will
continue with Knight - fi trying to
regain the pawn and White has two
choices first Bishop to c5 I don't like
it the simple reason is after Bishop to
b7 attacking the moon and when White
Castle we can simply castle on the Queen
side which confirms that d6 pawn is a
goner
and even though White has moves such as
a for an f4 they are not enough to
generate any kind of pressure to the
black
for example I can show you a sample line
if white plays the moon a fool then we
can capture on d6 and after pawn takes
Knight takes Knight takes and pawn takes
suddenly we have the equal material but
the opposite color bishop is on the
board and most importantly there is
ongoing pressure on the d3 pawn which
gives black a completely balanced game
so d6 Bishop c5 doesn't give any promise
to the white camp probably the most
critical response is Knight to d5 and
here certainly black has to know what
he's going to do about this vision here
comes the second important memory marker
guys when white played the move Knight
to d5 the move you have to remember is
Knight captures III so we are removing
the dangerous dark square bishop and if
white wants to play Knight to c7 then
he's more than welcome as after King to
d7
we are also threatening the folk on c2
the best response goes as follow pawn
takes a three so now what is threatening
on c7 but we can calmly defend
everything with rook to b8 and as you
can see once we can play King to d7
Bishop to b7 I think it is white who is
having trouble in this line fortunately
I get one game against a 2288 opponent
and I like to show you how trappy this
line is as my opponent continued with
rook to Sieben trying to go on a juicy
c7 square
I simply responded with King to d7 so
now in the view of d6 pawn is hanging
look to c7 is not a big threat kindly
note that Castle at this point is a big
time blunder as after sim
Pal King kept sd-6 white can no longer
capture on f7 due to the shaft we six so
Castle is right out of the equation the
only critical no in this position is
night to be four which has a merit of
playing the move rook to c6 but black is
not in a hurry as we can continue with
rook to b6 and get over pawn back
there is a nasty trap in this line if
white become greedy and played the move
rook to c7
which looks like winning the pawn on f7
as after King cats sd-6 and the muru
captures f7 white is still ahead in
terms of material but it is now black
stone and black will throw this forcing
sequence which instantly gives black a
completely upper hand first start with
ePHI attacking the knight Knight has the
only square namely c2 now the other
piece come out with interest Bishop to
b6 in Whiting white to grab the second
Pole and finally our last rook will come
into the picture with rook to c6 came to
d1 and now look to c8 forcing again this
night to go back on a very passive
square
Knight to even it's amazing that even
though white is a couple of points up in
this position his King safety is a big
time problem for example after rook to
Steven Chad king to e2 and now star mu
looked to be one which completes the
mop-up job the point is whatever white
plays let's say either b3 your rook
captures at 7 our rook will come to
their fate and that gives a completely
mating attack to the white cake well in
the game white plays rook captures at 7
but
the game finished very quickly with rook
to f8 threatening Bishop to g4 and white
probably underestimated how dangerous
his position is as he continued with b3
which allows this nice sequence Bishop
to g4 check King to d2
rook to F to check King to C 3 and after
rook to Steven Knight to c2 and root cap
to see do we have a picture Chad made on
the ball so this is one of the wonderful
trap aligned exist if he operon goes for
rook to c7 check the second move I want
to consider in this position is castle
on the Queen side which personally I
think is a dubious move and the simple
reason is after Bishop to b7 White has
some problem in the long diagonal
well again the most critical response
sd-6 attacking denied but after Knight
to f5 Bishop to c5 as the White has
castle on the Queen side this C file can
be a disaster a venue for the white camp
I like to show you how quickly y can
perish in this line as one of the game
in the database continue with King to d7
trying to get his pawn back and obvious
enough white played the move d4 try to
open the D file where black king is
sitting okay we have he captures d4
Bishop captures d4 now comes this very
nice move rook a to see it trying to win
a piece with before so white King get
out of the trouble with King to be won
but then black deliver this forcing
sequence the shock captures G to look to
g1 Bishop to f3 attacking the rook and
when white played the moon
rook
III black give him this rude shock
oh what a boom obviously white cannot
capture this Rukh as night captures d4
and black position is far better so in
the game
why take back the rook with the bishop
but that simply allowed this bishop to
e4 pin and King to c2 doesn't help as
after rook to see it a three and move g6
we reached the end game where white has
this dark squared bishop and black has
this night and obviously when black
munched this pawn this position is quite
favors the black camp last but not least
what happens if White Castle on the
Kings side which I personally think
probably the most critical response and
when we replied with Bishop to b7 kindly
note that if at this point white
continue with d6 then it will transpose
to the line which we have looked at
earlier for example d6 Knight to a5
Bishop to c5 and do you remember yup
it's Castle on the Queen side which
gives black a completely safe position
so obviously the most critical response
here is to play d4 twitch too much
surprise so far never has been played in
any games and against this if you really
want a sharp game then I have covered
the move before in the PG in where black
will remain upon down but he get a nice
counter play but I think the safest
option in this line is you should
capture on the d5 pawn which by force
get to this ending with Knight captures
defy
she captures defo and now why can
certainly grab an extra pawn with D
captures ePHI but because we have the
opposite colored bishop on the table
this is again a completely safe scenario
for the black camp so far I have reached
this position only one time in my game
and I just like to show you how quickly
I have drawn the game with castle on the
Queen side my opponent responded with
rook check and after King to p7 as the a
to pawn is hanging he responded with a
three
now comes the surprise package with rook
to e8 and suddenly white is in a dilemma
as he cannot properly defend on the e4
square for example Bishop to d4 is a
completely bad move due to the simple
tactical blow the shock captors g2 and
black is somewhat better and the other
move f4 again fails due to the hanging
bishop and Epix will ruin the white game
so considering all this here white has
the only option
Bishop to f4 but that allow us to play
this very nice move g5 so hydeia is very
obvious white can take it as at the end
Luke to g8 create some huge problems in
the white cam so white response is force
white has to play Bishop to g3 but after
Bishop to c4 look to d1 h5 trying to
trap down the bishop so s3 but now we
can simplify everything with Bishop to
b3 rook captures room and after rook
captures d8 yes white is upon up but it
is now black who is in in charge of the
game as he has this moves such as rook
to d2 as well
Loup to d1 which can give him the
instant draw so this is the only line
where okay white is upon up where black
has some initiative and position remain
quite safe for the black camp that's it
guys this is all you need to know to
play against the move Bishop to e3
remember play this critical break d5 and
after he captures d fire and the MU
night to be four by force we are
reaching to this end game where rather
than playing the move Bishop to a5 which
is an old move my personal
recommendation is you continue with beef
I followed by Bishop to b7 and as I've
shown in this video no matter however
white respond black get a very
comfortable and safe position in almost
all the variations thank you for
watching this video feel free to like
subscribe and comment and I'll see you
in my next episode bye and take care